if there's one place in germany
conservative parties could rely on it's
here in bavaria but geograndhala says
that slowly changing
in 2014 he became the first green mayor
of isil thing a village near the
regional capital munich
people were skeptical about a green
party mayor here it doesn't really fit
they were watching for what the green
party can do in the countryside and now
some people say it's not that bad they
tell me it's good what you're doing a
new style more open closer to the people
for decades the christian social union
had brought support in this part of
germany taking about 50 percent of votes
at each election especially among
farmers like jorgen bauer
but with only a few days to go he still
hasn't decided who he will vote for
there are many traditional csu voters
but they say they won't vote for the csu
anymore i think it's also because of
covid but a lot of things are not
working anymore the way people want them
to
the upcoming election will mark the end
of chancellor angela merkel's 16 years
tenure and with her gone many say it's
time for change the csu is the bavarian
backbone of angela merkel's christian
democratic union the two parties
campaigned together filled one same
candidate but finding someone to fill
merkel's shoes has not been easy
recent poll shows the social democratic
party is in the lead even if the gap
with the conservatives is narrowing many
put that down to armen lashett the cdu
csu candidate who hasn't been as
convincing
it was very focused on the person we
have a very strong personalization of
this election campaign what is also a
little bit new for our political system
because we had here for longer decades
very strong parties
the program of the parties was very very
important but we see also in this
election campaign that candidates and uh
yeah advantages and especially also
failures and mistakes of individual
candidates made made a big difference
climate change and social justice have
dominated the campaign and some of the
cdu votes could go to the green party or
the social democrats
here
it's a shame that merkel doesn't want to
run anymore cdu people are a bit
unsettled and are scared that things
won't be the same although they
shouldn't be renewal is important
everyone believes that from all parties
so it's good to have a new coalition
germans are expected to spread their
votes among more parties than usual the
election will be followed by coalition
negotiations that could last weeks if
not months it's not yet clear whether
germany's conservatives will be included
but abdul al jazeera bavaria in southern
germany